je touche et je crois que c'est une
réussite
je crois
j'avais tellement le trac et donc
j'étais que somme ça me gâcher le
plaisir qui pouvait y avoir à faire ça
et je l'est moins après 25 ans de
carrière avoue fièrement son nouveau
aujourd'hui vous estime que jamais avec
son mouchoir relancé des craintes
et d'un
sa voix n'a pas changé soyons là
souligne que les gens champ de force et
c'est bien moi qui chante doucement
c'est la nature qui a fait ça mais mais
j'aime pas quand il ya que ça gêne
vraiment pas j'aime bien qu'il ya aussi
la main qui aussi le corps qui est une
façon de bouger une élégance un truc
et puis aussi de l'intelligence un peu
enfin moi j'essaye
sa vie dans tous les sens pour savoir
s'ils s'avèrent l'existant
sauf on nous raconte que 500 fois répété
il a demandé d'envoyer à défaire de gens
ravis
j'ai fait des chansons pour dire ça pour
dire que ça n'allait pas et qui est en
fait ça m'a rendu heureux le noeud le
regard des gens les retours que j'ai une
mèche ans on a fait que j'ai une vie en
or depuis 20 ans 5 ans 10 ans
les fesses j'écris
celle qu'on a fait
ou plus